queridos amigos amigas importantes este
vídeo ha sido posible gracias a darling
cada día pasamos más tiempo en internet
y sabéis que con el nivel extra de
seguridad que nos proporciona das line
se navega mucho más tranquilos das lane
es la herramienta todo-en-uno para
gestionar tu identidad digital no solo
te recordará toda tu información del
pago y tus contraseñas sino que también
te ayudará a generar nuevas contraseñas
seguras sin que tengas que romperte la
cabeza daschle y funciona con todo tipo
de dispositivos y sistemas mac windows
android en safari en chrome etcétera
etcétera
además también te proporciona el
monitoreo de la edar web escaneando la
web en busca de datos personales que han
sido filtrados o robados alertando tal
instante en caso de que tus datos
personales se encuentren donde no beben
a tu vida mucho más sencilla y beatas
link.com barra visual política s para
usar das link de forma totalmente
gratuita en tu primer dispositivo y si
luego decides irte a la versión premium
usa nuestro código visual polítiques
para tener un 10 por ciento de descuento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pedro castillo candidato de perú libre
un partido de izquierda marxista ganó en
segunda vuelta a las elecciones
presidenciales del 2021 en perú durante
la campaña a este candidato planteó la
posibilidad de nacionalizar empresas
terminar con el modelo de pensiones de
capitalización castigar las
importaciones y suspender acuerdos de
libre comercio entre otras muchas
cuestiones
como demonios pedro castillo ha ganado
las elecciones como han podido los
peruanos votar por un líder como éste
porque más allá de si hubo o no
irregularidades con alguna que otra
papeleta lo cierto es que castillo
cosechó un enorme apoyo popular y si la
respuesta más fácil sería decir que ha
ganado porque keiko fujimori era muy
mala candidata o tal vez también por la
cob y 19 al fin y al cabo la gestión de
la pandemia en perú fue una de las
peores de todo el mundo pero tuvo los
peores registros en términos de muerte
por millón y una de las recesiones
económicas más grandes sin embargo un
momento porque lo cierto es que hay más
mucho más y eso es precisamente lo que
queremos ver en este vídeo
[Música]
cómo es posible que el perú una de las
rock star de latinoamérica durante las
últimas dos décadas haya decidido votar
ahora por un presidente que habla de
marxismo o nacionalizaciones y de nuevo
otra vez en latinoamérica de la
sustitución de importaciones es decir un
presidente que parece querer volver a
echarse en brazos del plan la estrategia
la política que tantas veces ha
malogrado a los países de latinoamérica
y que de forma más incomprensible que la
mezcla de arenque es con chocolate
vuelve una y otra y otra vez a la
primera plana política de la región pero
qué demonios pasa que en latinoamérica
no quieren dejar atrás la pobreza pero
porque no copian lo que funciona si es
que basta con copiar queridos amigos
amigas de visual política que se esconde
tras la victoria de pedro castillo
atentos
[Música]
cuando se malogró el perú
y en 2016 publicamos este vídeo
perú una nueva potencia en latinoamérica
fue uno de los primeros vídeos que
hicimos sobre esta región del mundo y
sabéis que en aquel momento amigos todo
apuntaba a que el país andino pacífico y
amazónico para que luego no os quejéis
los que nos veis de perú iba a comerse
el mundo los números eran tan buenos que
parecía casi imposible y que las cosas
no salían bien
queréis alguna prueba pues tomad nota
desde el año 2000 el país había
registrado la segunda mayor tasa de
crecimiento económico de toda
latinoamérica desde ese mismo año 2000
la inversión anual se había multiplicado
ni más ni menos que por 5 y las cuentas
del gobierno se situaban entre las más
saneadas de todo el planeta hablamos de
una evolución económica que había
logrado que la pobreza se redujera a
menos de la mitad pasando de niveles por
encima del 50% a poco más del 20 en
apenas 15 años
e
con semejantes datos el perú parecía
preparado para meterse de lleno en la
champions de los países más prósperos
con las cuentas públicas saneadas muchas
nuevas empresas brotando por todo el
país un crecimiento medio por encima del
5% la inflación controlada y los
capitales extranjeros llegando a
raudales todo parecía listo para que la
economía nacional rivalizará con el
despegue de las economías asiáticas más
pujantes
[Música]
ojo es que perú se ha convertido incluso
en uno de los países con más acuerdos de
libre comercio de todo el mundo acuerdos
que le dan vía libre a todas las grandes
economías del planeta en eeuu china la
unión europea japón con el sur del reino
unido canadá o australia entre otras
muchas en total para que os hagáis una
idea perú tiene acuerdos de libre
comercio con más del 80 por ciento de la
economía mundial una política app que le
permitió al país puedes multiplicar casi
por seis sus exportaciones entre el 2000
y el 2019 lo que evidentemente supuso
una enorme creciente entrada de divisas
extranjeras así que con semejante
panorama la pregunta que estoy
convencido muchos os estáis haciendo en
este preciso momento es qué demonios
pasó para que de repente las cosas se
torcieran tanto en el perú
pues un momento porque lo cierto es que
toda esa prosperidad empezó a encallarse
en el año 2016 y poco a poco lo que iba
viento en popa ya toda vela pues empezó
a ir más y más despacio por ejemplo si
entre los años 2005 y 2009 el país
promedio un crecimiento del 6,5 por
ciento anual entre el 2010 y el 2014 fue
del 5,8 por ciento y entre el 2015 y el
2019 de apenas el 3,2 un nivel
insuficiente por ejemplo para seguir
reduciendo la pobreza y de hecho tras
casi 20 años de fuerte crecimiento en
2019 el 70 por ciento de la población
peruana no había sido capaz de pasar de
nivel el 70 por ciento las
infraestructuras a todos los niveles
seguían siendo calamitosas y la
prosperidad percibida parecía ir a menos
y luego para colmo para colmo llegó el
coronavirus que fue tal y como os hemos
contado algo así como la gota que colmó
el vaso y amigos llegados a este punto
sé perfectamente cuál es la pregunta que
nos estáis haciendo pero con todo qué
demonios pasó en perú como logro un
candidato como castillo hacerse con la
mayoría popular pues atentos
[Música]
ah
institucional
podríamos hablar del 2000 del 2005 del
2011 o prácticamente de cualquiera de
los últimos años del perú y lo cierto es
que la historia la historia no cambiaría
demasiado eso sí con un matiz las cosas
han ido a peor y 2016 amigos fuego así
como el disparo de salida para una
especie de marca ahora cuenta atrás
hacia la autodestrucción vale no quiero
ser exagerado dejémoslo en que en el año
2016 dio comienzo una nueva turbulenta
etapa en lo político en lo social e
incluso también en lo económico y es que
en ese año 2016 hubo elecciones y el
resultado pues no pudo ser más complejo
en las presidenciales pedro pablo
kuczynski se hizo con la victoria en
segunda vuelta por poco más de 40 mil
votos frente a keiko fujimori sin
embargo de las legislativas el resultado
fue totalmente diferente fuerza popular
el partido de keiko se hizo con 73 de
los 130 escaños esto es con más de la
mitad de los diputados mientras que el
pp cae el partido del presidente apenas
logró 18 y ahí amigos fue cuando las
cosas empezaron a ir de mal en peor por
un lado frente a cualquier ápice de
responsabilidad política fuerza popular
decidir con todo contra el gobierno de
kuczynski y el parlamento se convirtió
así en un terreno hostil para el propio
gobierno
y como os podéis imaginar supuso frenar
muchos de los cambios que el gobierno
quería liderar y para colmo por momentos
el acoso fue muy pero que muy duro
responsabilidad política el interés del
perú primero está claro que un momento
porque si va a ser tan solo el comienzo
al poco tiempo una bomba política iba a
poner patas arriba todo el país en
diciembre de ese mismo año 2016 la
unidad anticorrupción de la fiscalía
general del productor debe investigar la
posible relación de kuczynski con la
constructora brasileña odebrecht si esa
empresa que prácticamente compró a todos
los políticos de latinoamérica
[Música]
pero ahí no iba a quedar todo un año
después de que la fiscalía comenzara sus
pesquisas la propia comisión la baja
todo el congreso peruano mostró pruebas
de la relación entre kuczynski y la
constructora brasileña cuando el primero
era ministro de finanzas según estas
informaciones una empresa propiedad de
kuczynski y afincada miami westfield
recibió varios contratos de odebrecht
poco tiempo después de que esta
constructora recibiera en 2004 la
garantía de que el estado peruano que
asumiría los riesgos económicos
derivados del proyecto energético y de
regadío de los olmos en el departamento
de lambayeque
hablamos de una garantía de casi 500
millones de dólares para una iniciativa
privada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es decir simplificando si la empresa
ganaba dinero con el proyecto de los
olmos engordaría su beneficio pero si la
cosa resultaba en pérdidas entonces
entonces pagaba al gobierno peruano
bueno así es como hacían negocios o de
'break' el caso es que a partir de ese
momento comenzó toda una guerra política
y el 15 de diciembre de 2017 el congreso
de perú admitió a trámite un primer
pedido de vacancia presidencial para los
que no lo sepáis la vacancia es una
figura por la que legislativo peruano el
congreso puede destituir al mandatario
invocando su incapacidad moral o física
vamos que con la vacancia del congreso
pues puede destituir al presidente le
puede mandar a hacer puñetas
la cosa no salió adelante entre otras
cosas porque kuczynski pacto con el
hermano de keiko fujimori kenji fujimori
su apoyo y el de algunos otros
congresistas más cambio de indultar a su
padre alberto fujimori cosa que
kuczynski hizo apenas unos días después
una decisión que provocó protestas
masivas y la renuncia de tres ministros
pero la cosa no se quedó ahí con más
pruebas el congreso intentó un nuevo
proceso de vacancia y esta vez
aparecieron unos vídeos de kenji
fujimori yo intentando sobornar a
congresistas con acceso a obras públicas
a cambio de votar en contra de deponer
al presidente
kuczynski un líder que había llegado con
un discurso de cambio o un mensaje ideas
frescas que le hicieron incluso ganarse
uno de los premios visual político
terminó dimitiendo el 21 de marzo de
2018 no siempre los planes salen bien lo
peor lo peor amigos es que el gobierno
de kuczynski inició entonces una campaña
masiva que luego continuó además su
sucesor martín vizcarra acusando al
congreso de perpetrar un golpe de estado
a pesar de que la vacancia es una figura
plenamente constitucional vizcarra que
por cierto luego fue bancado también por
acusaciones de corrupción y de nuevo en
medio de enormes protestas en total
cuatro presidentes en una misma
legislatura y veréis cuál es el problema
pues veréis por un lado este tipo de
comportamientos genera un enorme
descrédito y desconfianza hacia las
instituciones tanto entre los propios
peruanos como entre los inversores
extranjeros por otro lado no seamos
ingenuos esta crisis política nos mostró
como ninguna otra las motivaciones
reales de los políticos peruanos que
conforman la primera línea de mando
motivaciones que no tienen mucho que ver
con el interés general son
representantes públicos que por así
decirlo han dejado muy claro que sólo se
representan a sí mismos algo que también
podemos ver por cierto con la corrupción
galopante que parece afectar a la
política peruana y ojo que no hablamos
del típico problema que nos podemos
encontrar en cualquier país
de un político que pone la mano para
nada
ah
todos los indicadores apuntan a que la
corrupción en las instituciones peruanas
es algo común las encuestas apuntan a
que el 36 por ciento de los peruanos
consideran a la corrupción como el
problema más importante el 26 3% señalan
haberla sufrido personalmente y más del
75 por ciento de todos los ciudadanos
peruanos consideran que la corrupción es
habitual entre funcionarios y políticos
de hecho según transparencia
internacional pero ha pasado de ser el
44º país menos corrupto del mundo en el
año 2000 a que en los últimos años su
posición ha oscilado entre los puestos
106 y 94
para colmo todo este tipo de juegos
políticos desvía la atención hacia temas
que nada promueven la prosperidad del
perú y eso eso tiene consecuencias el
tarjetazo y el estado pasivo
[Música]
amigos amigas durante los últimos 20
años el perú ha registrado una
importante mejora económica que entre
otras cosas ha engordado los ingresos
del estado un estado que no ha dejado de
crecer en empleados públicos en muchos
casos mediante lo que se conoce como el
tarjetazo esto es colocar a familiares
amigos y compinches de todo tipo a
cobrar del erario público y lo que es
aún peor todo este incremento de
empleados públicos no se ha traducido en
una mejora real del funcionamiento del
estado los grandes problemas de hace 10
años siguen siendo básicamente los
mismos que hoy y para colmo durante este
tiempo lo que sí ha crecido es la
burocracia claro algo tendrán que hacer
todos estos nuevos empleados ahora bien
de problemas hablamos exactamente pues
fijaos
[Música]
a pesar de tener una salud financiera
envidiable la escasez de
infraestructuras en el país es tan
acusada que según el foro económico
mundial la calidad de las mismas solo se
encuentra por encima de las de venezuela
bolivia y paraguay hablamos de un gap
que algunos cálculos recientes sitúan en
unos 300.000 millones de dólares lo que
por supuesto afecta a la actividad
económica
y os doy mi palabra podéis creerme
cualquiera que haya estado en perú sabe
perfectamente de qué estamos hablando
luego el sector financiero está tan poco
desarrollado y tan cerrado a la
competencia que los peruanos tienen más
dificultades para acceder a la
financiación y sufren tipos mucho más
altos lo que por supuesto pues perjudica
la inversión para que os hagáis una idea
los pequeños préstamos con tipos del 20
y el 30 incluso el 40 por ciento no son
algo extraño y de hecho lo que se conoce
como el express bancario esto es el
margen con el que trabajan los bancos
que es en perú de más del 14% frente a
poco más del 3% en los países de la ocde
y eso no es todo para colmo apenas el 7%
de las empresas peruanas logran acceder
a la financiación bancaria de la misma
forma los mercados de capitales están
infradesarrollados la bolsa de lima por
ejemplo es una broma y el sistema de
pensiones lleva en punto muerto y
necesitado de reformas desde hace ya
muchísimo tiempo por ejemplo el sistema
privado de pensiones similar al modelo
de chile- apenas cubre el 20 por ciento
de los peruanos en edad de trabajar
además es un modelo cerrado a la
competencia con comisiones muy altas que
devoran la rentabilidad de los
partícipes y respecto al sistema público
casi mejor no hablemos la pensión media
mensual es de poco más de 150 dólares al
mes y eso
quien tiene la suerte de recibirla
porque entre otras cosas hay que
trabajar más de 20 años
[Aplausos]
en total el sistema privado y el sistema
público de pensiones apenas cubren al 30
por ciento de los peruanos mayores de 65
años el resto o reciben algún subsidio
pequeño del programa pensión 65 o
directamente no reciben nada que es
exactamente lo que ocurre con más del 40
por ciento de los mayores
luego las empresas públicas son un
desastre apenas son capaces de invertir
muchas se han convertido en nidos de
corrupción y en algunas incluso los
puestos de trabajo son hereditarios por
un acuerdo sindical y desde luego no son
rentables petroperú por ejemplo acumula
pérdidas de más de tres mil millones de
dólares durante la última década una
petrolera perdiendo dinero de forma
sostenida en el tiempo desde luego
cuando estas cosas sabes que estás
hablando de latinoamérica y aún
podríamos seguir
[Música]
la educación es paupérrima los planes
urbanísticos están tan desfasados que
desde el 2001 más del 90% de las
expansiones urbanas se han llevado a
cabo de forma irregular cuando no
abiertamente ilegal en el campo que
genera más del 30 por ciento de todos
los empleos del país la mayoría se
mantiene en condiciones de subsistencia
sin apoyo información mecanización o
desarrollo de cooperativas y
asociaciones
pues no se puede es algo que por cierto
favorece que como alternativa se opte
por plantaciones de coca y ojo que perú
es el segundo mayor productor de cocaína
de todo el mundo
cultivos de coca en perú se expanden a
72 mil hectáreas según la casa blanca
pero es por detrás de colombia el
segundo productor mundial de cocaína es
un suma y sigue constante pero sabéis
que todas estas cosas para los políticos
peruanos parecen secundarias y eso a
pesar de que terminan teniendo
consecuencias sociales y económicas
[Música]
t
por ejemplo se calcula que hay entre
25.000 y 50.000 millones de dólares en
proyectos mineros detenidos ante el
rechazo social simple y llanamente
porque el gobierno no ha tenido el
liderazgo de buscar fórmulas que
favorezcan a las comunidades locales
hablamos de una fuente de riqueza
potencialmente enorme que por ejemplo en
países donde las cosas se hacen bien
como australia han propiciado una enorme
prosperidad que generan
[Música]
y bueno la mala prensa de la minería
pues es comprensible en el pasado se
permitieron muchos abusos a cambio de
bueno recordáis lo que decíamos de las
coimas en el país pues a lo mejor tuvo
algo que ver el caso es que en el país
no hay impulso a la innovación la
política de atracción de inversiones es
insuficiente no hay desarrollo de zonas
estratégicas o polos de actividad el
gobierno peruano tiene unas finanzas
saneadas y pero parece no saber hacer
nada más por así decirlo avanzar con la
especie de piloto automático que ya es
claramente insuficiente para impulsar el
desarrollo pero que eso sí permite que
muchos sectores estén en manos de una
élite que se protege de la competencia
[Música]
amigos en entornos corruptos y en los
que sólo cuenta la supervivencia
política
la selección de líderes y profesionales
no se realiza en base a la meritocracia
sino sobre todo a la lealtad eso provoca
que cada vez los cuadros de gestión
tengan peor nivel lo que a su vez
alimenta la falta de capacidad para
tomar medidas y la falta de honestidad y
transparencia no nos engañemos en el
mayor problema del perú no espero
castillo y el mayor problema del perú es
lo que ha conducido a un político como
castillo a ganar las elecciones y
llegados a este punto la pregunta es si
era castillo un peligro para el perú
desde luego las cosas no pintan bien
aunque ojo porque puede que al final el
agua no llega al río castillo no tiene
mayoría parlamentaria y no es
descabellado que se parezca más a humala
que a personajes como gusta
habrá expropiaciones no habrá
estatizaciones no le vamos a quitar su
propiedad ni ahorros a nadie queremos
una economía popular con mercados la
independencia del banco central será
respetada porque ha hecho una buena
labor de mantener la inflación baja no
estamos en la idea bolivariana lo
queremos desmentir pedro francke asesor
económico de pedro castillo en cualquier
caso un apunte que mensajes como el suyo
también en la política peruana no son un
buen augurio y el riesgo está sobre la
mesa pero no nos engañemos y el problema
ya estaba en casa y no es otro que los
políticos que han convertido las
instituciones peruanas en su parque de
atracciones particular pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti qué futuro
crees que le espera al perú bajo el
mando de castillo déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte
abisal político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]